how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and it
seems like today we might be connecting
the sp umc or the sony pictures
universe of marvel characters to the
marvel cinematic universe
specifically venom and venom in
spider-man 3 and there's even
a crazy rumor going around right now
that venom could possibly show up
in guardians of the galaxy vol 3. now
right off the bat when you hear that you
might think that that sounds pretty
insane
but in this video later on i'll explain
how it might actually be possible
but first we'll start off with a
connection of venom to spider-man and
how eddie brock could be making his
marvel cinematic universe debut as venom
it seems like marvel and sony were kind
of hinting at this with the morbius
trailer that we saw
putting michael keaton's character
vulture that we saw in spider-man
homecoming that exist
in the mcu in the morbius trailer making
him exist in the sp umc
and now marvel and sony are playing very
well with each other so it seems like
these two universes may be colliding in
a very specific way we'll talk about all
of this
in this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a mysterio funko pop just
subscribe
like the video and leave a comment below
to enter so the biggest question
i think right now with venom 2 and
spider-man 3
are is spider-man going to appear in
venom 2 and
is venom going to appear in spider-man
3. now it definitely seems like marvel
and sony have a very specific plan
giving us vulture in the morbius trailer
and putting a picture of spider-man
in the morbius trailer with the words
murderer over it this implies that these
two universes do
exist one within another because at the
end of spider-man fire from home
spider-man was pegged out to be a
murderer and his identity as peter
parker was revealed
and this makes it possible that venom
could actually make his way over
to the marvel cinematic universe since
he exists in the sp umc
and they're now seemingly combining but
how exactly would venom
make his debut in spider-man 3 well as
it turns out there's
actually a really good theory about how
this could happen out there
right now here's one of the ways that
venom could enter spider-man 3 and it
all has to do with jay
jonah jameson first of all we know that
jay jonah jameson is going to be
in morbius we also know that he's going
to be in spider-man 3 because he was
also in spider-man far from home so he
is another character that exists in both
universes and he's the character that
could connect eddie brock to peter
parker
venom to spider-man and here as far as i
can tell is the best and most
logical way that venom could appear in
spider-man 3.
the theory goes with jay jonah jameson
looking to fully bring spider-man down
and now aware of the existence and
talents of eddie brock he could turn
to him for help to successfully continue
with his campaign against the young mcu
hero
jameson will need someone to find out
more about peter parker
his backstory the origin of spider-man
and all his missions so he can paint him
as the villain he's so convinced he is
and eddie brock could be the man he
needs for such a mission
eddie brock will come to jameson's
attention thanks to cletus cassidy
the newspaper mentions his escape and in
the post-credits scene of venom
eddie was getting ready to interview him
in jail cassidy's escape will inevitably
bring attention to eddie's interview
where jameson will get an idea of his
talents as a journalist and how we can
help him with his anti-spider-man plans
and as eddie will also know about peter
parker thanks to jameson's reveals he
will surely be interested in finding out
more about him and his actions as
spider-man
though how honest jameson will be with
him about his true intentions of
bringing the web slinger down
is unknown and this theory comes from
screen rant so full credit to them but
let's talk about this for a second
this actually is quite a good way to
bring tom hardy's venom
into the marvel cinematic universe and
into spider-man 3. it's basically saying
that the events of venom
2 will set up venom to appear in
spider-man 3.
because if we're being perfectly honest
spider-man probably won't appear in
venom 2
if venom is going to appear in
spider-man 3. we're either going to get
venom in spider-man 3 or spider-man and
venom
2 we're not gonna get both we'd love to
see both happen but unfortunately it
probably won't
but this is a perfect setup for eddie
brock to go to new york
he's a journalist of course he's going
to want a huge story
especially if he has an insider like jay
jonah jameson and of course he has the
venom symbiote to eddie brock that would
give him an
edge over any other reporter in the
world because he's going to be going
after
essentially a superhero or to the
public's eyes right now
a super villain but after eddie would
find out about spider-man slash peter
parker he would be fairly confident that
him
and venom could take him down so maybe
not only could he get the story about
peter parker and spider-man but he could
also be the one to catch him and bring
him
in and obviously this would be extremely
good for eddie
and surprisingly jay jonah jameson is
going to be a very big character
it's very interesting that they brought
him back specifically they brought back
jk simmons the original actor that
played jay jonah jameson in their
original sam raimi spider-man films this
implies that there could be some
multiverse stuff happening here but
that's for another video
but he's done plenty of interviews and
he said that he's already filmed a lot
of scenes for
other movies that he's playing j jonah
jameson in and we know that he's going
to exist in the sp umc
and the mcu at the same time playing the
same character so he could very well be
the key to combining these two universes
and him reaching out to eddie brock
because eddie brock's going to have some
fame to him because of cletus cassidy so
he'll reach out to him about spider-man
and perhaps
this is how venom is going to appear in
spider-man 3.
now we're going to get into the venom
symbiote in the guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 film but first let me know what
you think
about that theory from screenrant in the
comments down below so about
venom and guardians of the galaxy vol 3
it's something that i think everybody
would truly love to see
but we're not talking about a cameo from
tom hardy as eddie brock we're simply
talking about just the venom symbiote
it's a rumor that's been going around
unfortunately the source isn't that
reputable
but it could very well happen because it
happened in the comics and it happened
in the animated series and if they truly
are bringing the two universes together
this would be something that would be
truly great to see right now the rumor
has it that the guardians of the galaxy
will travel to klintar the artificially
created planet which is home to
the symbiotes according to the rumor
this sequence will be in flashback form
and will take place before
the timeline of tom hardy's venom so
this will actually be
before we see the symbiote on earth and
before we see the symbiote bond with
venom but it will still be the venom
symbiote now if we were to see this
scene it would take place in the past
but guardians vol 3 is not going to take
place
in the past this would simply be a
flashback or a scene that we see in the
beginning of the movie and then the
narrative jumps to the future
right now there's been a lot of reports
and rumors about what exactly we can
expect
to see in guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
and this by far is one of the most
interesting rumors that we've heard so
far especially when you consider
that most of the guardians of the galaxy
in the comics have actually worn the
venom symbiote in the comics rocket
raccoon has worn it
drax has worn it and even groot in the
comics they hook up with flash
thompson who is known as agent venom and
flash thompson and the rest of the
guardians of the galaxy end up on
klyntar because the venom symbiote ends
up taking over drax
and when he takes over his body he ends
up piloting the ship to
klyntar and what happens is not really
what you would expect
when they get to the homeworld of the
symbiotes flash thompson goes outside of
the ship against drax's warnings and
then the symbiotes actually take over
him and use him to speak to the
guardians
the symbiotes say that they want to
speak to the guardians by temporarily
bonding with them
groot ends up accepting and after group
is bonded and is not harmed the rest of
the guardians accept as well and they
are bonded with symbiotes
and from there the klyntar tell the true
story about the symbiotes they say that
the symbiotes are benevolent and seek to
maintain
peace across the galaxy by bonding to
worthy hosts
in order to create the ultimate noble
warriors however for the full potential
to be reached the host must have
a perfect blend of moral and physical
ideals something very few members of
very few species possess
they then state that if the balance is
not present then the symbiotes become
corrupted with bloodlust and turn into
vicious monsters and then these monsters
become disconnected from the hive mind
of the good
symbiotes but they continue to spread
across the galaxy they then explain that
they
are aware of venom's activities on earth
but they were unable to reach it until
flash joined the guardians of the galaxy
however when they tried to reconnect the
venom symbiote to the hive mind they
found that its corruption was too great
and it caused it to lash out in
confusion and anger
and then it headed back to earth but
they then said that the klyntar hive
mind states that flash has proven
himself worthy of being the newly
cleansed
venom symbiote's host and that as a
member of the hive mind he will have
access to new information and
abilities dubbing him an official agent
of the cosmos and a warrior of the
galaxy protector of his homeworld
against those who would do it harm
so it really is quite a very cool
sequence that we would love to see
happen in guardians of the galaxy
vol 3. now of course just because it
can't happen doesn't mean that it will
right now it's just a rumor and not a
very strong one at that but the fact
that the sp umc and the mcu are starting
to kind of combine
and the fact that the guardians do have
a history with klyntar
and the symbiotes means that this
actually is possible now
but let me know what you think about
this would you like to see the guardians
of the galaxy
visit the homeworld of the symbiotes in
guardians 3
and what do you think about venom in
spider-man 3. let me know what you think
in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things related to the mcu
and the sp umc for live updates you can
follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof